ACTUALLY CAUSE IT.
ANTHONY?
>> THANK YOU.
>>> A NEW REPORT SUGGESTS
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ
PAID MONEY TO AN ACCUSED SEX
TRAFFICKER WHO THEN GAVE IT TO
THREE YOUNG WOMEN.
THE STORY ON THE "DAILY BEAST"
WEBSITE FOLLOWS A "NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORT OF AN
INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER GAETZ
HAD A SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH A
17-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
CHIEF WASH CORRESPONDENT MAJOR
GARRETT SHOWS HOW GAETZ FACES
MORE POTENTIAL LEGAL TROUBLE.
>> Reporter: THE NEW REPORT
OVERNIGHT ALLEGES GAETZ SENT
CLOSE ASSOCIATE AND ACCUSED SEX
TRAFFICKER JOEL GREENBERG $900
IN TWO LATE NIGHT VENMO
TRANSACTIONS IN TWANTS.
ACCORDING TO "THE DAILY BEAST,"
GREENBERG USED THE APP TO SEND
THREE WOMEN, INCLUDING ONE WHO
HAD RECENTLY TURNED 18, VARYING
SUMS OF MONEY THAT AMOUNTED TO
$900.
IN THE ONCE REPORTEDLY PUBLIC
VENMO TRANSACTIONS EXAMINED BY
"THE DAILY BEAST" BUT NOT
INDEPENDENTLY REVIEWED BY CBS
NEWS, GREENBERG MADE THE
PAYMENTS TO THE THREE YOUNG
WOMEN WITH A DESCRIPTIONS,
TUITION, SCHOOL, AND SCHOOL.
GREENBERG'S EXPECTED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO SOME FEDERAL CRIMES.
THAT DEAL COULD INVOLVE
COOPERATION WITH A SEPARATE
FEDERAL PROBE INTO GAETZ'S
CONDUCT.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES FAMILIAR
WITH THE INVESTIGATION,
GREENBERG USED SO-CALLED SUGAR
DADDY WEBSITES TO FIND FEMALE
PARTNERS FOR GAETZ.
GREENBERG'S LAWYER MET WITH
REPORTERS YESTERDAY.
>> I'M SURE MATT GAETZ IS NOT
FEELING VERY COMFORTABLE TODAY.
>> Reporter: THE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER GAETZ
HAD A SEXUAL ENCOUNTER WITH A
17-YEAR-OLD GIRL GREW OUT OF THE
GREENBERG PROBE.
THE GAETZ INVESTIGATION HAS
SINCE WIDENED INTO OTHER
MATTERS.
IT WAS LAUNCHED DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILLIAM BARR'S APPROVAL.
GAETZ HAS DENIED ALL ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
>> IT IS A HORRIBLE ALLEGATION,
AND IT IS A LIE.
>> Reporter: CBS NEWS REACHED
OUT TO GAETZ'S REPRESENTATIVE
FOR COMMENT ON THESE MOST RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS, BUT WE'VE NOT
HEARD BACK.
WOMEN WHO WORK IN GAETZ'S
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE, NO NAMES
OR TITLES GIVEN, SAID, WE
UNIFORMLY REJECT THESE
ALLEGATIONS AS FALSE.
WE'VE SUBSEQUENTLY LEARN A
SECOND SENIOR AIDE TO GAETZ
RESIGNED OVERNIGHT.
HE'S SCHEDULED TO ADDRESS A
WOMEN FOR AMERICA FIRST EVENT
TODAY AT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S GOLF CLUB OUTSIDE MIAM